tell us what you do tell us what you do
i am a bus driver with the city
uh a people mover if you will
i've been doing it for 15. we all know
what a bus driver is yeah he only
confused us more
yeah that's good so uh yeah i've been
doing that for 15 years now give or take
and uh
it's uh i love there's tyler the creator
and this is tyler the over explainer
i'm a bus driver you know we move people
in a large rectangular
vehicle and i'm towards the front conan
i used to be a mover i said i was a
relocation technician wow wow
that's i think that's fair if you had
said that i would have assumed you were
a mover there we go absolutely i like to
tell people i dabble in the comedic arts
and then they look at my work and they
uh they disagree so you um
so you uh you're a bus driver
and i'm curious are you a fan
of the movie speed
and do you think uh because that's
really i think that's the only action
movie that's ever been made about a bus
is that correct
the gauntlet oh what's the clinton
eastwood and is it tying daily where
they they kind of have to go through a
whole like
armored city area on a bus clint
eastwood and tyne daley i know why did
you know that right away that's crazy
did you watch it yesterday probably if
not this morning well i'm sorry speed is
and and we're forgetting tyler here
tyler speed is one of two bus movies yes
yes and um really only two saunder lock
sorry his former wife but there is a
movie he made with tyne daly okay yeah
uh but that was um i think one of the
dirty harry movies was it yeah okay
again you've taken us down you're very
good at this
a cul-de-sac where there's nothing to
eat there's no house there's no fuel
there's no house
i'm sorry he takes you down
conversational cul-de-sac you know when
they start to build a land development a
planned community and then they stop but
there are still cul-de-sacs in the
middle of a field and there's just grass
growing up uh that's where he takes us i
don't disagree no thank you which means
you agree yeah uh yeah listen tyler i
will not ignore you anymore and i
apologize for my friends they're the
worst that's okay
i'm happy to see them both for the
record yeah thank you thank you i'm
shocked to see you don't do anything i
thought sona would have taken the day
off with today being what it is hey
that's right it's 4 20. yeah i've got a
happy hour planned but i'm not sure it's
after bedtime for my boys i am an adult
now so i always say congratulations on
the kids uh
i'm sure you're sick of hearing it from
everybody
oh that's
nice i i'm actually curious if anyone's
ever pooped on your bus oh yes
yeah right absolutely i can't believe it
that was my next question that's insane
right here it was where are you from
and then underneath i wrote in
parentheses if bus driver has anyone
pooped on your bus that was
he was a bus driver it said if bus
driver and then an arrow goes right to
has anyone pooped on the bus
that's how well i prepare so you're a
bus driver and people no they have not
no one's come on your bus has anyone
come on your bus and said keep this
above 50 miles per hour or i poop on the
bus
no no but i have had a gentleman drop a
deuce on the bus
uh i've had another gentleman who ringed
the bell to get off and just dropped
trout and took a leak and then just
walked off as if it was something that
everybody does and then for the next few
stops it's running up and down the aisle
okay but but that's right you're going
up hills and then downhills and yes i
see there would be like a tidal flow yes
oh come on my question is
he rang you said he rang the bell to
stop the bus
then urinated that's correct so there
was an anticipation of him urinating
and that's so cool that he didn't get p
shy like he you know here comes my stop
i should pee now
rang the bell right i mean you know i it
takes me a little while to just sort of
chill
you know i sort of have to visualize
different historic events and then i can
i can urinate okay i can't be conscious
that it's about to happen it has to
happen exactly i'm like that i'm like
that as well so tyler uh
wow so being a bus driver is not all fun
and games you have to deal with people
who are misbehaving wildly have you ever
felt like you were threatened on the bus
oh going
uh uh
all the time all the time first did you
just fall in did you just fall in love
with me
she went oh
conan oh conan i wouldn't be here if
that hadn't taken place long ago
thank you